good morning everybody welcome to
the virtual meeting of the licensing
regulatory committee
11th for december 2020 i am councillor
mark newman chairman of the licensing
and regulatory committee
can i first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements
please ensure that your microphones are
muted when you are not speaking
please do not interrupt other speakers
please use your hands up function
to report a bacony on pecunary or
non-pecuniary interest
or to notify the chair that you wish to
speak
and or make a proposal members are
reminded not to use
the messaging chat function during the
meeting
if you are attending a meeting to speak
and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
additionally you may will be invited to
speak and ask
questions by the chair please await your
turn
i would like to remind everybody present
that this meeting will be
broadcasted live on the internet and
will be capable of repeat viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential and exempt items if you
make a representation to the meeting you
will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also considered to be
being recorded by the council and the
possible use of those sounds recordings
for webcasting
and training purposes the council
members of the public and the press may
record film or photograph or brought
cards
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully
excluded okay
now i'd like to introduce the officers
attending the meeting um david would you
like to introduce yourself please
david price licensing officer emma
emma rich bell assistant manager food
safety and licensing
uh nigel nigel de lou legal advisor to
the
committee and can good morning karen say
a governance officer
okay right we're now moved to apologies
for absence
thank you chair apologies received from
councillor dawson
and councillor grandin and
i don't believe that councillor creswell
is with us this morning
okay thank you decorations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
please
use your hand function if there is any
no none received right
we now move to confirm the minutes of
the meeting held on the 9th of october
2020
are there any points regarding the
accuracy of the meeting
no could i have a proposal please
i'll propose to sue
and can i have a second to please i'll
propose mr chairman
thank you and um governance officer
uh will you take over
thank you chair councillors could you
please open
the vote in the modern.gov app by
clicking the plus sign in the top right
of the agenda screen and selecting
attendance
and voting
in the voting tab the vote for this item
will show in blue please click on the
blue line to open the vote
mine's not working i don't think i've
clicked it and the blues gone off
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
counselor newman have you had trouble
voting
yeah let me just try it again i did i
clicked it on the blue and the blue went
off let me just do it again
uh vote in
idea right if not i can take your vote
verbally
oh it's come up now uh let me just click
it for i might as well try and do it
properly because that's what we've got
to do
confirm confirm
has that gone as a for
[Music]
excellent and that was unanimous thank
you
okay um oh that's the
minute's been accepted and i will sign
them at the first
opportunity right to receive
notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
sorry chair none received okay thank you
karen
um any questions by councillors
none received chair okay right we now
moved
to paper blr 20 stroke 5 hackney
carriage table
affairs the licensing office dave
price will do a report now please
thank you chair i'll briefly summarize
for you
um this report is to consider responses
received during
the public consultation exercise
received against the revised table
affairs for hackney carriages
operating in the controlled zone of
favourite of the baby district
which the licensing and regulatory
committee approved for public
consultation at the meeting of the 9th
of october
i have set out two options there for you
to consider today
the first option that you consider no
change is necessary to the revised table
affairs that was advertised
or option two that you're reminded to
modify
that table and then from there you
have recommendations on to cabinet
and i would take questions from their
chair
okay any any questions for david please
any hands up there
no i don't think there is any questions
nope right um
hello it's councillor mabry trying to
get from one screen to another to um to
actually
ask questions um okay if i may mr
chairman
um can i ask the uh licensing officer
david price
a few questions please of course we've
we've obviously
had some uh re
uh replies from the licensing trade
um and i wonder if we can discuss those
or is it not appropriate at this moment
we can discuss them in the debate i
think or david
do you want to answer any questions now
on that or should we wait for dubai
i can ask her any questions now chair if
you wish okay
yep yep margaret if you'd like to ask
david some questions then um thank you
uh mr chairman
um have we just had the two replies
mr price please there will be three
replies
three three in option in in appendix c
there are three replies
there are three okay um
thank you thank you um
and we i do
i i recall when we were discussing this
before
um we were looking at one taxi
driver being the representative of the
um of the trade did that occur
or are we just taking all these um
individually please
no it's not a word of one taxi driver
the consultation goes out to the whole
of the taxi trade we did a
a consultation previously back in
february
and as you know that's why this is
coming back and we did another
public consultation in august before we
even got to this stage
so this is a combination of the
responses we got in august and why the
table affairs has got to where it is
today
right so so not one um taxi operator was
talking for the trade in the end
no not one individual okay thank you
thank you
um i can see that you've had these
written
replies did you have any verbal replies
as well please
no verbal no no okay
fine um and can i just ask whether
you have actually gone back to these uh
taxi
operators and ask for further
information or
have we just taken what they have
supplied
submitted
chad um i'm going i'm going to reply but
i think my
my um the assistant manager wants to say
something as well but i will say that
each of the three
have have been responded to
okay emma would you like to say
something yeah thank you chad i also
wanted
perhaps to remind members if they
weren't aware that we um also had a
meeting
via teams um earlier in the year between
the initial constitution and the most
recent one
where all of the trade were invited to
participate in a in a sort of round
table discussion as best as we could
virtually
um so we've taken also a lot of
information from that meeting and fed
that into the proposal before you today
thank you mr chairman mal come back
again yeah
certainly um thank you um
uh miss richbell from that
initial meeting via zuma an
internet meeting that you had can you
remind the committee how many of the
operators were
were there please
i can't as chair but david or emma can
you remember how many was there quite a
few wasn't there
yeah i can't remember the exact numbers
can you david but we had i think we had
about a dozen 15 or so
people at that meeting which were
representing either operators or
individual drivers
it was very successful we got a lot out
of it actually
yeah there were quite a quite a lot of
the trade were there
so it wasn't a representative of an
individual one or two
it was a a raft of um
the trade there was about at least 12 as
as um emma richbelt said there were
a lot there thank you mr chairman i
would like to state and i would like it
minuted
that i did request to join in this
meeting because i'd had
representation from some of the taxi
drivers however um that invitation or
they promised
um never came forward um so for that i
i would like to personally apologize to
the taxi operators because i was not
involved in that meeting um
thank you for answering those questions
so far
okay thank you right um
right we now move to debate but to start
it off
um i'd like to sorry i think we've got
council of beer with his hand up
yes oh sorry it's not coming up on the
screen with me here
just knocked it off because i had to
move the arrow to the
mic because i've got that off when you
said you were moving on
um two points following on from um
councillor uh mabry um
i thought i i also said at one of these
meetings that i wanted to be involved in
that particular meeting um but i don't
remember
hearing any more about it but um i
certainly
do remember it coming up and i think
counselor maybe may have been the one
that
highlighted it and i said but i also
feel i need to
be involved but anyway moving on can i
just ask
sorry to the officer they're not debate
these questions
thank you very much but that that was
pointed out and i just want to be clear
that
i also wasn't invited um
the um these
fees that we've now ended up with
um are they aware
are the taxi drivers aware of these and
were they aware of these
in august when you had the last i think
it was in august you said you had the
last communications coming in from them
these three
people uh have they commented on these
fares and if they have how many people
have comment how many taxi they've all
they've all the taxi drivers david can
come in when he likes but all the taxi
drivers have been contacted and the only
three letters we've got of what were
on the paper today i don't know david if
you have anything to say on that
but the table affairs were was drafted
following the the august
meeting with with the trade so from that
meeting the
table was drafted from that stage we
talked to
um a raft of operators
and there are the main there are eight
main uh operators and seven one-man
bands of hackney cage
proprietors and then from there
everybody each driver has been written
to
and each operator has been written to as
part of the consul public consultation
exercise
and you've not then had any responses
back
from those uh objecting or in favor
that's really what i'm trying to get to
apart from the three that you've got in
front of you in those papers they're the
only responses that we've had
and they were from individuals rather
than from
a organization speaking on their behalf
you've got two two operators
yep so two two main operators and one
one man band thank you
okay thank you all right is any more
questions for the offices
i'm looking for hands all right no hands
up
we'll now move to the debate so start
the debate off
i'd like to move that we um go for
option one
i think we've discussed it on several
occasions we've given it a lot of time
it did go to cabinet and it did come
back quite rightly
uh we did have a consultation with all
the taxi drivers and i thought that was
really successful
it's gone out to them all everyone's
aware of it all
we've had three letters not really
complaining about it but with different
suggestions
which you will get that you'll never
make everyone happy they'll always be
this and that you could do this better
or not
so i'm quite happy to propose option one
before we go to debate have i got a
seconder please
a second chair all right thank you sue
right i'd like to move to debate is
there any discussion on this from anyone
please i've got my hand up i don't know
if you can see yeah i can see that now
peter very good thank you
i'll put it down there and speak um uh
if we agree these are the option one no
change
um i'm sure it's there somewhere but i
just it's
gone from your mind um when are we
likely to review this
and or do we have to wait for some
situation to cause us to review it such
as like
a massive increase in fuel charges
or we get requests from the taxi drivers
or do the officers suddenly dream it up
for some reason
which is quite acceptable um can you
answer that please
i think that would be one for the
officer again david
thank you chad we will review these
annually
and also in light of any changes
so if there's any changes within that
year if
if it's necessary or if the trade feel
that they
need to want anything amended then we'll
take those comments on board
coming back on that mr german so that
means that you would
uh you would bring it to our notice uh
we'll just say
june time next year um or would it be
december time
um just saying that um we're
we're not going to review any um
anything to do with the taxes or that we
are hey would we know that that's what
i'm trying to get out will there be a
bullet point on one of the agendas it
comes into action on the april the
first next year uh obviously after it's
gone to cabinet peter but uh
david peters question there
yes it will come it will come back
before members to
either say that they wish to go back out
to consultation again or not so
yeah we will look at it and then
determine whether it actually needs
revising or not if we don't feel it
needs revising then we'll come before
you and say
you don't need to revise it and just
following that through
if the taxi rank uh
people uh write an ask or request for an
increase
would that trigger anything to us or not
it depends on the request so if if
you discuss with the chairman and voice
chairman i would have thought right
that's fine thank you
all right thank you peter margaret
mayberry
margaret thank you thank you chairman um
i i would just like um perhaps it's a
debate rather than than a question but
it may be classed as just a question um
the appendix c from mr hale
uh he's talking about the larger
vehicles are
majority used in majority are used for
wheelchair users and his concern was
about
um discrimination for disabled users
has it been pointed out to mr hale that
under 4.4
um there is the operational discretion
um and that the taxi drivers do not have
to charge the larger
or the higher rate for those larger
vehicles
please i believe they are aware of this
but i will check
david do you agree with this that they
are aware i think we discussed this at
the meeting
yes each each um proprietor is aware
that they can charge
less than the um maximum table affairs
and if i may come back mr chairman mr
price and um
mr hale was um happy with that answer
was he
well we i don't think we had any
problems with that at the meeting it was
discretionary wasn't it they can um
charge less if they wish it's
discretionary now with the current table
affairs yeah
yeah yes i i understand that mr chairman
but
you had a meeting in august the email
from mr hale is dated the fifth of
november
and he is still asking the same question
i'm going to suggest to you um and i'm
asking
whether it he has been replied to and he
acknowledges that he does not have to
pay the higher
rate
uh david can you help with this mr
chairman i doubt
whether the the um taxi uh
driver would respond to say that he's
aware that he can
he can charge less i'm not sure whether
he'd bother to do that
so so i think we may have to take that
that if we've replied in that vein that
he can
charge less that it's entirely up to him
then but i i
understand what councillor maybe is but
it was discussed at the meeting anyway
so anything to add david
do you want me to comment on that uh all
i can say that that
each each um each respondee in this
phone
has been has been responded back to and
i have actually had a
a a short verbal conversation with um
with mr hale but um as each driver is
aware
that they can charge charge less than
than the maximum we do that in in
writing
we did that in writing as part of the
consultation process
and we will be doing it again as part of
part of whatever
you decide um thank you
that's your answer margaret they are
aware thank you mr chairman and
that was my original question and you
can look at it at the recording
i did actually ask if there had been any
verbal conversations
since these emails were received
um and obviously the answer from the
officer is that there have been
verbal conversations so thank you all
right
thank you margot right is there any more
debate on this
otherwise we'll go to the vote
no right well we'll go straight to the
vote then um
um karen can you conduct the vote please
thank you chair can i just check with um
david price do we need to set a date
yeah that would be the other you first
off decide whether you're
doing option one or option two in this
case you're doing option one
and then you will need to set a date
thereafter yeah well i've proposed
one i've got a second after option one
and then do the next
next uh part of the recommendation to
cabinet after that one
would the fifth of april be a reasonable
date chair
right so i'm happy with that
birth of april everyone happy with that
officers happy with that um margaret
uh yes mr chairman um i we
will remind you that that was the date
that i actually suggested previously
thank you
well thank you for your suggestion
margaret okay right now can we go to the
vote on this please
thank you chair so we've got a
recommendation to cabinet that the
revised table of fares be adopted
and that the um varied table affairs to
become effective
from the 5th of april 2021
yep very great thank you councillors
could you please open the vote in the
modern.gov
app again by clicking the plus sign
in the top right of the screen
again
the plus sign peter then yeah i know
that
it disappeared from me
and then you got a vote in that voting
to confirm the minute all right
log on in the voting tab
the vote for this agenda item will show
in blue
um it says logon's failed so i'll
i'll verbally vote for it
okay please click on the blue line to
open the vote if you haven't already
done so
i don't know why that's happened but
it's not actually trying
i've tried it twice and it was the logon
failed
i'll just try it once more before you
close it
peter you may have to go right into the
early log on
you know when you log on and put your
password in you may have to do that
again
well i sound but anyway i'll just try
this oh it's arsenal password perhaps
that's let's try it just bear with me
i'll be very quick
[Music]
all right
oh yes it's loading oh no it's gone
right back to being
oh i can't do all that uh should i take
your vote verbally please
yep thank you and is that a vote for uh
four
that's unanimous then chair okay
so that is now carried um is it office
is there any more business or is that
all done all for today chair yeah well i
thank you all for attending
and thank you for voting this through
and let's hope that um the taxi drivers
will be happy with what we've done for
them thank you very much
sorry mile i did ask i did ask to bring
up about the taxi
says if the committee quite happy for me
to contact suffolk county council
if i can explain to those i hadn't
emailed i found out that the
taxi fare from sudbury to west suffolk
60 pounds return
however those who have the vouchers
because they don't have a bus pass
they will only accept 20 pounds towards
that
so it needs to be looked at because
obviously from when this was decided
there's been a lot of changes okay i'm
quite happy for you to contact county
councillor and um if you keep councillor
beer
in our county councillor i'm sure you'll
back you up
thank you very much i've already been
involved in it with uh councillors
yeah and can i just say the reason
that i then gave a verbal vote was
because i would have to have done what
was suggested come right out and start
all over again that would have taken too
long
thank you very much
you